france woke to a new political horizon a
hung parliament in which president
macron's authority has suddenly been
undermined
one paper called the country
ungovernable france is not accustomed to
such political uncertainty
there were strong gains for the left a
new group uniting socialists and greens
is now the official opposition
it's only a couple of months since
macron won the presidential election but
now his reform agenda notably his plan
to raise the retirement age is in doubt
his popularity punctured
here in marine le pen's hometown there
was a sense of triumph her far right
party the rn going from eight seats to
89.
we wanted to make emanuel macron a
minority president and it's done and we
also wanted to have the means to defend
our position
le pen may have lost the presidential
campaign but her party has benefited
from the soaring cost of living she said
the result was way beyond her dreams
so delight for marine le pen but of
course misery for emmanuel macron five
years ago he dominated the center of
french politics so much
that he squeezed the life out of the far
right and the far left but now they have
both bounced back so spectacularly that
we have a hung parliament and france is
about to enter its most volatile and
divisive period of politics for decades
macron will have to try to be a more
inclusive leader now
but that change won't come naturally to
him or his country
the rn party doesn't have the same
opinions and i think that's a good idea
especially regarding the cost of living
petrol prices energy bills
there will be changes and i think it's a
good thing
and french politics is fractured
nobody unites this nation
and even here on her doorstep many are
still wary of le pen
her political program is quite
interesting but the fact that she's
against the veil against muslims and
against migrants it puts up a block for
us
around here the echoes of an industrial
past that's left a legacy of disfigured
land economic strife and high
unemployment the political landscape may
be about to enter its own era of scars
and discord
adam parsons sky news northern france